no no
thank you thank you
this victory belongs to you you did this
for every family that has been shipped
and squeezed and hammered we're going to
fight for a level playing field and
we're going to put people back to work
yeah yes to all the small business
owners who are tired of the system
rigged against them we're going to hold
the big guys accountable to all the
seniors who deserve to retire with the
security they earned we're going to make
sure your Medicare and Social Security
benefits are protected and that
millionaires and billionaires pay their
fair share and to all the young people
all the young people who did everything
right
who did everything right and are
drowning in debt we're going to invest
in you
to all to all of the service members and
your families who have fought so hard
for us we're gonna fight for you that's
right I love you
and all the women across Massachusetts
to all the women across Massachusetts
who are working your tails off you
better believe we're going to fight for
equal pay for equal
to all of you this is your night this is
your victory yes oh
this this was this was a campaign that
broke records raising more money from
small donors than any Senate campaign in
the history of this country and not
being on more doors than any Senate race
and mass
an amazing campaign and let me be clear
I didn't build that you built that
and you did what everyone thought was
impossible you taught us scrappy
first-time candidate how to get in the
ring and win
you took on the powerful Wall Street
banks and special interests and you let
them know you want a senator who'll be
out there fighting for the middle class
all of the time
and despite the odds you elected the
first woman senator to the state
yeah I love you too and I don't I don't
have to tell you this was a tough
campaign senator Brown and I had our
differences but he and i just spoke and
he sent his congratulations I hope
you'll all join me in thanking senator
Brown for his service to the comp
Bruce and I wish Scott and Gail and
their daughters nothing but the best
i also want to speak tonight to Senator
Brown supporters the message you sent
was clear we need leaders in Washington
who are willing to break the parties in
gridlock and work regardless of party I
know I didn't earn your vote but I
promise I'm going to work to earn your
support
there are many people to thank tonight I
start with my husband Bruce
I also want to thank my kids my
beautiful grandkids my brother's my
in-laws my cousin's my nieces and
nephews here in Massachusetts and all
across the country senator caring
Governor Patrick
Mayor Menino Mayor Menino thank you for
your support for your encouragement and
most of all for your leadership you were
real fighters in my corner and I
appreciate that but it's what you do
every day for the people of our state
that is truly remarkable thank you thank
you
and to our congressional delegation to
all of our mayor's and legislators
council members and sheriff's to the
nurses to the firefighters to the
teachers to Labour's to men and women of
the building trades and to all of our
brothers and sisters in the labour
movement
I love you too to the LGBT community
to the women's groups
to the environmental groups lenta
to the ministers I'm so grateful to the
credit unions yes but my credit unions
to the more than 700 small businesses
supporting us to the student organizers
to the committee's all of you all of you
all of you have had my back and I
promise you I'll have your back
and I want to thank the single best
grassroots army that any state has ever
seen
for every volunteer who knocked on doors
who stood in the rain and held signs who
talk to your neighbors and for my
incredible staff that work more hours
than I thought was humanly possible
thank you thank you all of you and to
everyone who shared your hopes and
dreams with me and put your faith in my
ability to fight for you I want you to
know this I will never forget I will
always carry your stories with me in my
heart I won't just be your senator I
will be your champion
okay so tonight isn't over because we
still have a lot of celebrating to do
yes but I want to close by noting that
it was exactly 50 years ago tonight that
Senator Ted Kennedy was first elected to
the United States Senate
we miss his passion his commitment his
energy in his fight for working families
that night 50 years ago he said that he
would dedicate all his strength and will
to serve you in the United States Senate
for 47 years he lived up to that promise
tonight I pledge to do the same
Oh